Can she see me yet?
I can!
This is pretty cool technology
you got here.
So, let me try that.
We’re playing footsies!
We should have done this in
outer space!
We could have both been
sitting on, like, Neptune,
in a bubble.
Hey, what have you been
doing for fun?
I have not left home since
March 8.
At all?
I went to an eye doctor’s
appointment
because I could no longer fix
my eye infection
on telemedicine.
And then I went for
a mammogram.
I asked what did you
do for fun.
Eye doctors and mammograms
do not qualify.
I have never had a mammogram,
myself
Okay, so for fun.
but it doesn’t sound fun.
You can do better than that.
No, it is, definitely, not.
Here’s what I did for fun:
I’ve had two girls here,
the whole time,
who were living in Los Angeles,
who moved here during
the pandemic
They’ve been fun.
We have movie nights, just the
two girls, Stedman, and I.
We do regular movie nights,
and I’ve seen all the movies I
wished I’d seen and didn’t.
We watched every episode
of “The Crown.”
We started a whole thing with
Popsicles, so we now have—
That sounds fun.
—twenty-three different
flavors of Popsicles,
including pumpkin,
and sweet potato.
And we have Friday-night
dance nights
We put puzzles together.
And I’ve read a lot.
What have you done?
You know, we went—
—for example—Michelle and
I went bike riding yesterday,
which was fantastic,
because it was a beautiful day.
And game nights
—big!—although sometimes,
I get too competitive.
At least, that’s what
Michelle says,
because she’s been losing.
Hello, President Barack Obama!
Hey you! How are you?
I’m so good!
You’re in Washington, DC,
and I’m home, in Santa Barbara,
but—through the miracle
of technology
—we get to be face to face in
the same room,
and we don’t even have
to wear masks!
And we have a fire going,
apparently!
And we have a fire going
—a real one, too!
I’m excited to talk to you
about your extraordinary
—I mean, I don’t even have
words for it,
—it’s a masterful rendering of
your presidency and life,
“A Promised Land.”
But first, I just want to
ask you,
What was the one word that would
best describe how you felt
when it was
announced that Joe Biden
and Kamala Harris will be
the next President and
Vice President
of the United States?
I was thrilled!
"Joe Biden"!
First of all, obviously, Joe
is somebody who
stood by me
on every major decision I
had for eight years.
He's become a brother
-a genuinely good friend.
Kamala was one of my
earliest supporters when I
first launched my presidency
So, I’m personally invested
in them.
And they have the character
and experience, I think,
to do an outstanding job
in a very difficult time,
a very challenging time, in
this country.
But, beyond the personal
investment I have in them,
I think this gives us a
chance to
get back to the kind
of competent,
caring government that we
so badly need,
and that the world expects out
of the United States of America.
So, it’s not going to
immediately solve every
every problem that we have
—because you have enormous
challenges, around COVID
and the economic after effects;
you’ve got long-standing issues,
like racial bias in the
criminal justice system,
and rising inequality
—but without this change, I think,
things would have continued
to deteriorate,
and our democracy would have
been much more fragile.
And I’m confident
a new President
and Vice President
are gonna help us
right the ship.